[Music]
a
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud L proud
and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__] up
[Music]
you shut your mouth when you're talking
to
me you shut your talking to
me Donald Trump's
lawyers get told to sit down and shut
the [__] up in the egene Carol TR
specifically Alina Haba apparently she's
objecting I object to what the objection
that's what I object to sit down and
shut the [__]
up this morning uh Donald Trump appeared
in a New York Court in this second third
fourth I don't know how how many
defamation trials will he have to go
through with egene Carroll because he
won't stop defaming her I mean honestly
I'm not opposed to him keeping doing
this this is
just making it to where it's going to be
harder for him to appear to be a
billionaire so whatever he wants to do
however much money he wants to give
egene Carroll I'm whatever he wants to
do I don't know maybe he should just
open up a bank account and just start
throwing money in there for her that way
he can just say whatever he wants about
it but this morning Donald Trump
appeared in
court as he Jean Caroll gives her
testimony or opening statement and he
won't even look at her apparently this
is a reports in the courtroom when she
gets up he won't even make eye contact
with her he's such a [__] [__] ass
little
[__] through and through all the way to
his little [__] puny little [__]
bones scared of egene Carol scared of
the truth
really that's what he's scared of is the
truth oh
well judge Kaplan though in the
courtroom 100% out of [__] no more
[__] to give couldn't couldn't find a
[__] the stock is not there the [__]
Factory is closed it's cold judge Kaplan
can't find one so he's told the lenina
habba to shut the [__] up uh in the
courtroom it's funny because at one
point I guess uh Alina hav was objecting
by sitting at the defendant's table and
the judge said hey look [__]
when you address this court you stand up
you stand up to address this court and
then he told her to sit down and shut
the [__] up you shut your mouth when
you're talking to
me
oh my God you can't get any better than
this than this drama and really honestly
this is
uh this is Trump's Mo this is going to
be him from for for the entire year just
embarrassing himself in
court also the
judge pointed out that Mr Trump should
keep it down when addressing his
attorneys because he doesn't want the
jury to hear what he's telling his
attorneys now obviously Donald Trump is
intentionally talking loud in the
courtroom and he's directing his
comments towards his attorney so that he
can have his voice
heard and so that the jury will hear
what he's
saying the judge has told Donald Trump
to shut the [__] up as well it's not
going well for him of course it's not it
never does because Donald Trump doesn't
understand reality he doesn't he doesn't
understand reality this
[__] white trash Silver Spoon
[__] that's
right he's rich white
trash he is you you ever met these
people just the white trashiest sons of
[__] you've ever [__] met in your
life you wouldn't [__] leave a
quarter on the counter around these
bastards because they would steal it not
because you don't need the quarter not
because you wouldn't give them the
quarter if they really [__] want
wanted it but you wouldn't leave it
there just so they don't steal
it that's who these pieces of [__] are
that's who Donald Trump
is you wouldn't want to be within
spitting
distance of this piece of
[__] but they love him they're going to
make him their nominee of course they
are why wouldn't
they they're just
as shitbox Nation folks shitbox
Nation I don't know hashtag it shitbox
nation is what manga truly
is and that's what they love about him
is that he's white
trash they truly love it I talked about
it several times on this
show about why [__]
rule dumpy ass white people like this
[__] somehow they like this guy
from New York New York City he's a rich
man he's got a tower he's an
elitist from the east
coast and they love
him
really come on
man but it's because he's white trash
that's what they love about him the
most in small towns all around the
country white people are racist as [__]
I mean just through and through and
through speaking that real quick about
white people being racist and small
rural white communities because I grew
up in one I was there I know all the
nword with the hard R jokes okay I know
them all I've heard them
all just speaking on this issue really
quick Nikki
Haley saying that racism has never exist
we our nation has never been racist
we're we're not a racist country Brian
we've never been a racist country we've
never been a racist country you [__]
bonehead are you [__] are you are you
[__] kidding
me we're racist now and then there's
that whole what's that thing oh slavery
segregation the KKK l mobs what the [__]
what the [__] are you what the [__] is
Nikki Haley talking about and by the way
speaking of Nikki Haley I'll get back to
the smalltown racism in just a minute I
promise I'm gonna get I'm gonna Circle
back around to that [__]
[__] yesterday we had Cliff Sher on and
we were talking about the South Carolina
primary and Cliff pointed out that
they're gonna I mean go [__]
fullon scorched Earth on Nikki Haley if
she makes it to South Carolina and they
will say anything and everything about
her and I said on the show that they
would even call her by her real name Nim
to Nikki
nimr and and yesterday Trump did it now
I don't I don't know if Liz Harrington
is still watching the show I me and gab
zanchez last year thought that Liz
Harrington was watching the show Liz
Harrington is one of Trump's
AIDS I don't know she's the one that
wipes his ass and Changs the diaper I
don't I have no idea if that's Walt or
her I don't know who's changing the
diapers and wiping his ass still Liz
Harrington apparently is still watching
the show so Liz I appreciate that
yesterday you heard me and Cliff talking
about how they're going to start calling
her by her real name nimada in South
Carolina but apparently they're going to
do it right before New
Hampshire all the stuff that we said
yesterday they were going to do to her
in South Carolina they aren't going to
wait to South
Carolina here's Nikki Hae like look
racism doesn't exist this country's
never been been racist and then Donald
Trump's like here hold my diaper hold my
diaper
okay now let's Circle back
around I wanna want to make this point
about Donald Trump being rich white
trash and that's the reason why white
trashy [__] people like this piece of
[__] I know these people I know these
[__] people [__] I am white trash too
okay I'll just say it I'm [__] white
trash too can't you tell now I'm the
type of white trash that has a couple
brain cells to rub together to
understand that people are trying to
deceive
me especially people who seem to be of
my
ilk just because I reached adulthood and
decided that [__] like racism and
bigotry probably wasn't a good idea
Liberty and freedom and rights was the
way to
go
but in small town White
America they're racist they are nimada
they're racist as
[__] they're racist Nikki we're we're
not a racist country Brian we've never
been a racist
country and I'll prove it to you but the
problem is is in small white America
small white rle
America a lot of times there's no one to
be racist
against okay when I grew up in my
town there was one black kid in the
entire school like not the high school
not the middle school not the elementary
the entire [__]
school there was no one to be racist
against so what happened is is that some
people in the town what the the the
sentiment that they would pour out is
that oh well we don't have n-words with
the hard R so we got those other people
those white people on the wrong side of
the tracks and they're just as bad as
black
people sou how it
worked sounds weird some people who
didn't grow up in small America small
town America smalltown White America
sounds
weird that's that's how it was it was it
was classism now not exactly racism
because they didn't have anyone to
really aim their racism at so they use
that
energy aim it towards other white people
in the town the white trash people now
how does that relate to Trump and how do
they relate in that way well Trump is
that with billionaires if you want to
you know kind of give it
a a billionaire type narrative
he is that with billionaires he's the
white trash
billionaire right they don't [__]
like him they don't want him around he's
a [__] [__]
box he's trash he's garbage hot garbage
I mean like flaming hot
dumpsters type
garbage and it don't want him around
they don't want him to pretend to be a
billionaire they don't want him in his
circles they didn't want him in New York
really especially after the [__]
[__] up real estate and casinos in the
early 90s went bankrupt several
times like it you don't like
it and that's who Trump is to these rich
white folks he's rich white
trash and that's how they associate with
him these ruled toothless brainless
rednecks who will believe anything this
[__] idiot says any sheep food that
he's willing to conjure up and shove
down their throats they'll [__]
believe it especially when it's
underpinned by
racism by bigotry by fascism you know
like the blood poisoning [__] when he's
quoting mine comp look I don't say it
the same way Hitler said it Hitler said
it in German I say it in American
American we speak American
here it's what it is that's how that's
how these people connect with
him that's why they'll defend him until
the very last moment of his life that's
right he's not going to lose his cult
following he will never lose them I mean
it'll chip away a little bit right he's
going to go from about 12 to 13% of this
country who are absolutely diluted do
not have enough brain cells to rub
together to make any kind of thought let
alone any kind of heated energy to to
come up with a fact or
two they're not going to leave
him it's
evident you saw the polls from Iowa the
real polls not not the [__] fake ass
media he this is going to happen and
then it doesn't happen that
way I'm
talking about the caucus about the vote
Jesus Christ the guy only received just
over 50% of the vote which is pathetic I
told you yesterday it's a pathetic win
it's [__] pathetic and I was really
disappointed and really pissed off
yesterday about how the media was trying
to spend this of course Keith oberman's
following my lead
I know maybe Keith's listening too
welcome Keith if you
are to listening to the rlin ball the
left I think that's really catching
attention I think that's the reason why
a lot of these producers are coming and
listening to this
show is because people have called me
the wrestling ball the left and really
people don't know what the [__] that is
they don't I don't have any idea so I
have to come here to figure it out
right
maybe that's why Keith followed my lead
but I was really [__] upset yesterday
as you noticed everyone thought I'd
probably be really happy um that Trump
won the Iowa caucus which I knew he was
going to that's not what I was you know
happy or upset about or to be upset or
to be happy about I was upset about
their coverage of it
because the fact of the matter is is
that there's a Civil War in this country
there is a civil war going
on and it's not between Americans well
it is but it's between the [__]
fascist Americans the ones who want to
embrace fascism they're just not sure
how much of it to embrace you know what
I mean like Paul Ryan Liz Cheney Chris
Chris look look we need thin veil it we
need to call it conservatism we need to
be old style Republicans
again we need to save our
party us and the democracy Coalition
want to save our country we can give a
[__] less about the party
honestly if if tomorrow the Democratic
party decided to disband and we needed a
new party fine whatever I don't give a
[__] you can call it whatever the [__]
you want to call it I don't give a [__]
you guys know I don't SE or shield for
any kind of [__] party how many
[__] candidates have I endorsed
officially endorsed since I've been
doing this how many count them
how many will I you can [__] count
them it's the same
number I mean I just call the [__] like
I see it I don't need to endorse
anybody but I could give a [__] less I
give a [__] less about what you call the
party I don't give a
[__] as long as the values of the party
are where I'm mostly at does that make
sense and right now there's only one
party there's only one major party in
this country only one and and we spelled
it out in
Iowa just this
week the evidence is there the evidence
is there that there's only one [__]
party major party in this country and
then you have people who pretend to be
Republicans and then you have the
fascist the America First Nazi party MAA
trumpism right anyone who will shield
for him anyone who is in his cult anyone
who will protect tend to be in his cult
you're maanga you're fascist you're not
actually a major party because you don't
have enough votes to [__] be a major
party [__] they can barely keep the
[__] government open they can barely
keep a speaker of the [__] house you
think this is coincidental no it's
because they don't have a party anymore
because they're at civil war with each
other and they don't believe in
democracy it's been a long time since
they really did believe in democracy
but it's more evident now than ever that
they truly don't give a [__] about their
country they only care about their own
power and their own power over someone
else and that's really the
disease that they have that they're
fighting for it to metastized now
it's it's gone viral in their
party Donald Trump says the Republican
party is 95 % maanga 95% I actually
don't think it's
95% I mean there's nothing more evident
than Iowa and really honestly it's kind
of a joke really I
mean yes we saw what what the Republican
caucus wanted in Iowa and it was
Trump overwhelmingly when you talk about
three four
candidates
51 to
49 he barely beat them it wasn't a huge
win it wasn't it was pathetic honestly
if you if if
really if he's such the Savior for them
if that's their idea why didn't 100% of
them vote for him if 95% of the
Republican party is
MAA why then why and these are are the
things that uh I've been trying to
say without needing to um you know dive
into deep into data and statistics and
bore you to [__] death every single
day on this show man I try to keep it
entertaining to some degree yesterday
was a great show we had we had clion
Monday we had Jess Piper we have a lot
of fun with people on this show and we
try to keep it light by watching you
know some videos that make you chuckle a
bit we have the sound effects and the AI
and all the great commercials and the
sounds and the music you know this show
some people have said that it's you know
a political show with tattoos and rock
and roll you know what I mean like It's
the Hard Rock political talk show with
tattoos just is I mean we do a lot of us
do drugs here a lot of us drink here
some of us don't but you're welcome
either way it's the beauty of the Tony
Michaels
podcast is we have a wide casting net I
mean Jesus Christ we have shares on
Facebook every day and he won't shut the
[__] up him in the shart Army I have
trolls all over YouTube you're welcome
to come and troll yes engage why do you
think we post most of these videos
anyways the way that we post them we
post them to piss you off and to make
you
comment to keep you engaged because
that's the most important part of this
entire [__] process all of it all of
it boils down to what you're engaged in
about your
democracy and how you were going to
engage in it yes uh there is there is
valid reason to believe that Engagement
online is is good engagement we have to
fight back
against the crazies on the books of face
and exchan formerly known as
Twitter
and in the YouTube comments we have to
push back on them of course we do but
also in real
life but the main thing that matters the
most is the
narrative and the media is horrible at
the
narrative I believe it because they
still think they control the
narrative and they forgot that it's 2024
and the [__] internet
exist they still haven't come to grips
with their loss of the
narrative and that's and that's the
reason why I have to do this show every
single weekday for two full hours and I
believe it's the reason why you would
come watch this show rather you [__]
love me or you love the [__] hate me
either way welcome and I love you
too I'm not scared of criticism I'm not
scared if you're offended by what I say
I don't even care if you think I'm
wrong most of the time I'm gonna turn
out correct
anyways because I don't
[__] make my commentary to make you
happy I don't that's why yesterday or
yesterday I was so [__] pissed off
about the media's coverage about Monday
night's Iowa
caucus because they're ridiculous
they're [__] ridiculous and they'll
continue to be ridiculous for the entire
year that's right they're not going to
they're not going to get any better than
they are right now I mean they've gotten
better I will say they've gotten better
and I don't know which
producers especially from MSNBC who
listen to the show every day they force
them to listen to the show um I'm not
sure on which shows they are but it
leaks out it leaks out I even got a
video from you uh someone sent it to me
in a Facebook private message and I got
a clip of this video of James Carbell
explaining why we need to mock these
[__] that nothing else Works
Data and facts and trying to [__] and
convince people that were smarter than
them that [__] doesn't work it doesn't
work trying to sit and ex let let me
tell you let me tell you why I'm smarter
than you and let me give you [__]
homework to go look up data to tell I'm
why I'm smarting you or to [__] bore
you to death uh so there's another um
Trump motion in court today uh it's very
significant um this court motion and the
reason why it's super significant
because um well you're going to want to
watch this entire 18-minute video on
this one Court motion that really
doesn't make a hell beans worth of
difference but uh I gotta sell you ads I
got I got ads to sell I got stuff to
sell you so we got to make a video on
this motion so we can sell you an ad
that way you you can buy things uh or
see this ad that way we make
money we make money when we talk about
worthless [__] [__] that doesn't
matter in the narrative makes no
difference whatsoever whether you know
it or you don't know it these facts
don't really care if you know them in
the overall narrative and making sure
that you engage in your democracy but um
I'm gonna sit here for the next 18
minutes and bore you to death so that
way YouTube will push ads to you and
we'll do a couple ad reads of some
garbage ass products that you wouldn't
want to buy anyways so stick around for
the whole 18 I'm serious that's how it
feels doesn't it doesn't isn't that how
it [__]
feels
we got [__] to do we got narratives to
[__] push we got to make sure that
this [__] country wakes up tomorrow
and understands that hey there's a
really big Choice coming around the
corner you can either choose uh I don't
know democracy or
autocracy what are you going to do you
going to drink the Kool-Aid are you
are you going to wake up and see the
[__]
truth and realize and realize that a
that a court Motion in any court or what
court date or what [__] 14th or what
the Supreme Court blah blah blah yakety
[__] schacky it is our job it is us
the people who will go to the [__]
Ballot Box got
it those people who showed up the 49% of
people who showed up in I in the Iowa
caucus those 49 [__] perent of people
who showed up at the Iowa caucus and
voted for someone else a lot of those
people went to vote against Trump and a
lot of those folks are going to go to
The Ballot Box in Iowa in November and
they're gonna vote for Biden because
they understand the [__]
Stakes who gives a they don't give a
[__] about no Motion in no [__] Court
they don't give a [__] they don't don't
give a [__] they don't care about some
[__] stupid motion that doesn't make
a hella beans worth of difference and
they don't care about your YouTube ads
or your ad reads either they don't give
a [__] nor are they even paying
attention or watching that 18-minute
video that you're boring people to
[__] death with
okay they're not get with
it talk about what the stakes are and
the stakes are if we don't engage in our
democracy if we count on some judge some
prosecutor or some Court to save us
we're [__] we're [__] and it's only
us that will save us that's it we the
people so pluck your head out of your
ass and develop some decent commentary I
don't care if it's on cable news or on
[__] YouTube or on Twitter or on
Facebook I don't give a [__] where it is
and where you're saying the [__] you're
saying grow some [__] nuts
understand the
stakes and give people some [__]
energy to get engaged and that's why you
come here every single [__] weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central for two full hours on the tubes
of you the books of face the twitch
machine and the
Instagrams don't go anywhere we'll be
right back I promise and we're going to
have that grifty grift right after
this what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast letters from the trucker
Convoy de's Tammy by the time we reached
DC we was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way we
got plenty of SL M gems
skull near run out Natty light hope it
don't rain tomorrow so we can Circle the
city again here's Bob dear Bob I'm
fixing to send you some more of them
Doritos you like the red bag not the LI
love and blue one in your absence I
discovered a rash on my neck and no it
ain't no hickey and I a even seen my
cousin brought in
ages stay strong wipe your ass at least
once a day yours Tam
me [__] them [__] [__] them [__] [__]
them [__] we're back to the Tony
Michaels
podcast welcome back to the show you
know what time it is it's time to grift
that's right we're going to
grift buffle your grift safety belt
because we have for you the super grip
gummies super grip gummies don't do [__]
for you please buy the super grip
gummies use the promo code we want to
make money we want to make money here at
the Tony Michaels podcast when you buy
your super gri gummies it's supergrip
gummies.com
um again they make you feel healthy not
really they make you feel great not
really they taste great not really they
taste like complete [__] [__] but buy
you some super Griff gummies because if
you don't oh boy we just won't get this
little bit of your money we'll get more
of your money later on I promise we'll
sell you law juice 1,000 or the bunion
stopper 5,000 one way the other so go
to supergrip
the real
[Music]
grip here's the real grip go to the Tony
michaels.com that's right go to the Tony
michaels.com hit subscribe it's
free it's free that's what a great grift
I got right and then if you pan on down
and you go to memberships you can also
join patreon for free it's join and you
can give money there you can actually
become a paid member now there's a few
advantages of being a paid member you
can view all the Sunday rants if you're
in any tier on the patreon you get to
view all the Sunday ants all of them and
if you buy your membership by the year
you get 10% off which a lot of people
are doing um so I appreciate all the
support you give there you also can join
the Discord server it's free too it's
free um it doesn't cost you anything to
join the Discord server it's not much of
a grift we don't really make any money
off the Discord server it's a great
place for you to go and hang out maybe
you want to join the book club that's on
the Discord
server or if you get you know really
lucky to get grifted you could link your
Amazon Prime account to the Twitch
account don't forget to renew that we've
had we had several people tie it last
month um but they didn't actually renew
this month so go renew your subscription
if you have your Amazon Prime account
tied to your Twitch account all the
directions are right here to do it for
free it's free it doesn't cost you a
single nickel uh it gets us a little bit
of money but it doesn't cost you
anything so it's kind of a you know what
now that I'm thinking about it that's a
shitty Griff
too all right well if you really if you
really want to give money to the Griff
the best Griff we got going right now is
next week Friday that's right next week
Friday I'm G to be getting my microphone
tattoo that says this machine kills
fascist that is
inspired by this merch design right here
this machine kills fascist with the
microphone you can get this you can get
this merch on the grift website bony
michaels.com you can get it there but if
you want to to see the live stream we're
going to live stream this
tattoo uh session you just go to the
team tattoo fund that's right be part of
Team tat 2 if you're part of Team tat 2
you'll see the live stream next Friday
on January
26 um so go to the Tony michaels.com
click the team tattoo fund give any
amount in this give it to me give it to
me give it to give it to
me now I think this morning I did the
math and if we get uh I think it was 30
people giving $20 we'll reach our goal
because all the money that goes into
this team tattoo fund goes all to the
artist every single bit of it all of it
will go to the artist either for ink
time or or for the tip whatever it may
be all that money that goes to team
tattoo fund will go to the artist I will
give every single bit of it um to the
artist when I go I've also got a hoodie
for the artist which is really cool the
tattoo Merch this design right here
that's on the TV uh so that that'll be
really cool but you guys get to see the
tattoo live stream I'm probably going to
live stream several times that day that
afternoon and that evening uh for you
guys to watch the tattoo process you can
see how much paint I'm in you can make
fun of me you can call me a [__] you
can do all that kind of stuff or maybe I
won't be in pain at all and you'll think
I'm some kind of tough guy either way
we'll see what happens just go to the
Tony michaels.com pan on down to team
tattoo fund put any amount any amount in
this fund a dollar $2 $10 20 some people
have been giving over $100 so just go
and put some money in that fund and I
will get your email and I'm GNA email
you those links uh for the live
stream um for the tattoo that day next
Friday on January 26 so that's the grift
that's it that's all I got that's all I
got the grift I hope that I hope that
makes you happy all right let's go let's
go to some clips here I want to show you
um
this
let's see uh I'm trying to find this
clip
of I'm trying to find this clip of Keith
Oberman I thought I I thought I retweet
yeah here it is okay here's Keith
Oberman he's peping his show here on
Twitter uh but uh he he does a show a
podcast now it's called the countdown
podcast which his Show on MSNBC years
ago I don't know if you know this but
Keith obman used to be on MSNBC until he
was fired um and Keith obman his Show on
MSNBC was called the countdown with
Keith with Keith Oberman but here he is
talking about his frustration with the
media over the caucus listen the
Wednesday countdown podcast is now live
no Trump didn't Crush DeSantis and Haley
in Iowa he beat the field by only
2,222 votes he only won 51 to 49 if
Biden only won a primary 51 to 49 they'd
cancel all television until the Super
Bowl and only talk about nothing but him
only winning 51 to 49 I think I said
that yesterday didn't I something like
that the cliff or in the a block I
believe I said something like that that
like if this was on the other foot and
this happened
then they'd racked the coverage they
continue to only talk only only talk
about Biden and how oh my God Biden
Biden Biden um so here here's we'll
finish up Keith here Trump is vulnerable
he's deteriorating and our itical media
in this country absolutely
sucks I agree with him I agree with
Keith the media [__] sucks they suck
at what they do and the reason why they
suck at what they do is because they
think they control the narrative that's
really the problem right so they think
they control the narrow they think
whatever they say is what the country is
going to believe they're like oh yeah
that yeah sounds sounds right to
be that's not how it works anymore used
to work that way you remember I when I
was a kid um in the late 80s early 90s
we come home before we got satellite
right this is this is a um you know we
didn't get satellite I think we got
satellite T I lived on a farm so we
didn't get cable and cable didn't come
out that far cable didn't come outside
of town you know it's just in town where
it was um but we had satellite TV I
think we got it like 1995 1996 some [__]
like that and at the time it was called
um I think it was called Prime Star you
remember that now they had the big huge
[__] satellite dishes you remember
that the ones that had to have a [__]
motor on it or you had to go out and
crank and point at the right [__]
satellite to get the channels that you
wanted [__] crazy [__] the big ones
the big [__] does anyone
remember those some
[__] now they're all probably in some
sort of scrapyard somewhere um but we
had we had a small satellite dish it was
called Prim star and that was that's
when we really that's when I actually
discovered what skinx was in HBO which
is kind of crazy because it was in the
mid 90s and I got to watch all the
George Carlin um HBO specials because we
got HBO at that time HBO came with the
[__] thing you didn't have to buy it
separately it all came together you just
got satellite and you got all the
[__] channels whatever they were you
got them you know what I mean it was
like 198
1996 is when we first got um Prim star
in The Farmhouse there and we only had
one TV we had a 13-inch TV that had the
satellite on it because you just ran one
[__] wire in the house and you hooked
it up to one TV we had a 13inch TV that
we watched that [__] on now but before
that before that time period right there
was just the evening news and then your
local news and your parents would go to
the grocery store and stop at the
grocery store and get the [__] the
newspaper because normally that time in
a small town there would just be a
couple days a week that they would print
the [__]
newspaper they wouldn't even print it
every day you know what I mean it'd be
threed day old news in that some [__]
but you go home parents read the
newspaper you'd sit down youd make you
macaroni and cheese and some hot dogs
you know what I mean and feed the family
and sit down in front of the [__] TV
and they and your parents would watch
the Nightly News the the Evening News
the local news for the weather and you
know who who died and then some local
[__] you know where what what house
caught on fire and you know what the
there was an accident on on the highway
84 you know that sort of
[__] and then they watched the Evening
News um the national news for 30 minutes
and that was it that was it and that's
what you that's what that's you're like
okay that's the news is you know what I
mean and Republicans in this country
realize that hey this is how people are
getting news and this is how they're
getting their facts and we don't want
them to have
facts what we we don't we don't want
them to have facts because the facts
they don't help us facts don't really
help us in our political
agenda so then what they started to do
is they started to think well how can we
because they can't stop the news you
know what I mean they can't stop the
news they couldn't stop that process at
that time they weren't highly advanced
yet in their methods of
delusion and manipulation and deception
right they weren't highly advanced in
manipulating massive amounts of people
in media yet yet oh they were going to
get really close really fast and that's
where talk radio came in because they
realized that people would listen to
talk radio all day long they they listen
to this [__] they listen to people Yap
about their local community and oh yeah
well let's see you Earl and he he he
went down and he [__] a couple sheep
at the sail Barn you know what I mean
and he bought bought him a calf and just
stupid [__] like that just stupid local
[__] and they listen to the radio they
listen to Talk Radio in the morning on
their way to
work maybe with some music peppered in
there Along came a guy named rush limau
you ever heard of him rush limau you
ever heard of that
[__] cuz there was no there was
no National
message on talk radio it was all local
talk conservative [__] yapping
and yelling and screaming no real
actual put together
narrative that could spread across the
nation so [__] eaters in Florida would
be saying the exact same [__] as [__]
eaters years in Seattle
right that's what they needed they
really needed that to delude
people to manipulate them to brainwash
them that's what that's that's what they
did in a long game rush and they
nationally syndicated Rush hell the
Heritage Foundation paid his syndication
fees for years and years and years and
decades
and that's how russling ball got on the
national in the National scene on AM
radio and he would broadcast from One
microphone one all over the country
setting a narrative but it's so
important when he set the narrative he
set the narrative at noon
Eastern for three hours noon Eastern for
three hours is what he said as narrative
at and it was so important to the
conservative movement to make these
people believe abs AB lies and the
reason why it was so
important is because they needed to know
why the media was gonna lie to him when
they got home that night are you
following me are you following me now
through this journey
down the [__] green brick road not the
yellow brick road it's not the Golden
Road oh my God this road is paved full
of [__] dumpster fires
and Nazi
rallies but russin ball would tell these
f [__] people what to
think about what the news was GNA tell
him that night because russling ball
knew exactly what the news was going to
tell him that night he knew he knew what
the news was that morning he knew the
news rooms were working up what the hell
they were going to say that's why he
came on at noon during that lunch
hour cuz anywhere where were you were at
in the country because Rush was on for
three full hours and he started at noon
Eastern he was very likely to get you on
your lunch
break listening to talk radio and he
gets you
hooked he get you hooked because he was
entertaining there was entertainment
value in his commentary and he would say
[__] that no one else would
say he would go out of Limb and push
National
narratives set the bar for those
National narratives
that's what he would do he didn't give a
[__] he didn't care what his critics
would say he didn't care what his own
party
thought he knew the only way to shape a
country was media and he knew the only
way to do it is through a national
narrative a
50,000 foot narrative not some [__]
detailed data poll in the weeds or some
[__] creating show after show after
show about little bitty motions here and
there and that's not what he did at all
I listened to him for years I vehemently
disagreed with the
[__] but his idea was very
effective his method was very [__]
effective
very it still
is and it's not just
effective it's not just effective on the
right it's highly effective on the left
too
because most people don't identify that
way you know that right A lot of people
who watch here would identify themselves
as liberals
lefties socialists maybe I don't know
Democratic socialists
Democrats but most people do not
associate themselves with left vers
right more people are starting to
starting to understand those ideologies
and where they fall in the political
Spectrum
but the
media they had the narrative back
then so how did the right undermine that
they would put rushin ball Sean Hannity
others on the radio before your parents
would get home at night to watch that
Nightly News to watch the local news and
make them predisposed of how they're
supposed to believe
it and that's how they shaped their
narrative and in the late '90s Along
Came Fox
News Not only was Russ and ball able to
shape their opinion of what the news was
going to tell them now they could
reinforcement with a cable news channel
that posed as news when it was just
[__] propaganda and lies noal
rules that's how we're in the situation
that we're in that is what's brought us
to this moment right
now where the America First Nazis the
magas the trumpet the
maglites the
maggots the Trump
humpers a video I found I refound this
video is several years old uh of a lady
I'll play it for you today it's
hilarious it's great but she calls them
the Cheeto the Cheeto humping [__]
nuggets now she says nuttier than
squirrel turds in this video which is a
phrase that I heard a lot when I was a
kid I've said it a lot nuder than
squirrel turds oh my God I love that so
she says that phrase in there
too so we'll we'll look at that too but
the point of all this is that the media
sucks because the media's still stuck in
the 1990s in the early
2000s they still think they control the
narrative they still think because they
got the Nightly News and a 30 minute
show that somehow they're going to be
able to shape what people think in this
country the problem is is a lot of these
people are [__] Elites
rather it's on a you a great YouTube
channel or several YouTube channels that
you love to
watch or it's the Nightly News or MSNBC
or
CNN they're
elitist it's what they
are they view themselves that way
whether it be poday
America whether it be other media
options in this in this
country a lot of people don't
like a lot of people don't like when I
say m as Dutch they [__] hate that
you son of a [__] what do you want from
me go watch it I don't know what to tell
you go watch it go watch MSNBC I speak
against Joe scarber on mning Joe and
meek all the time too and you're not as
offended by that why are you so offended
Brian Tyler Cohen go watch him too he's
[__] boring he tries to cuss like I
cuss but he doesn't really get there you
know what I mean
and the other thing too is stop calling
it corporate media I know I know I know
I know there's some folks out there that
like to call it corporate
media and some of it is Corporate media
but some of it is not corporate media
some of it is not corporate media that's
trying to pretend to be corporate media
might as touch they're trying to pretend
to be corporate media and they're
they're not so corporate media does not
define it that well tyt isn't corporate
media that's a [__] grift for Jen
gunger it's a grift for him that's not
corporate um someone asked when does
Brian Tyler Cohen cuss uh
well he cusses in his shorts and it's
again he doesn't cuss cuss he lays them
in there strategically so he does
because he doesn't want to fend the
YouTube algorithm or whatever you know
they they don't like cussing
so Andre says Tony cusses with heart and
soul bam bam I do I see it as profanity
poetry if you want to know the honest
truth that's how I view my cursing it's
it's very it's very good um hap happily
a says I like MC I like M such you
should like them whatever you want to
like that's fine I like them too I like
the my zealous brothers [__] I I know
Ben Brett Jordy I I know
them I know those guys I like them
too Koko says leave them alone
Tony I'm listen look we got a long fight
ahead of us this year there's a long
hard slog and a long hard fight right
and what we have to do is we have to get
people engaged we have to have a very
high turnout and the reason why we need
a huge High turnout it is so important
listen to me listen to me very carefully
it is so important that we have a such a
big
turnout not for the sake of the top of
the
ticket listen it is going to be easy to
beat trump it is going to be easy there
are going to be way more people going
voting against him than there are even
going and voting for Joe Biden
specifically Jesus Christ haven't you
seen these videos at like New Hampshire
and Neil Cavuto asking these people hey
uh if uh if it's if it's Trump and Biden
on the ticket you're a Haley supporter
you going to vote for Trump they're like
[__] no [__] no I'm not voting for that
sun [__] that [__]
traitor I'm vote for
Biden people more astonished by this we
need to lean into this now the most
important reason why we need to lean
into
this the most important reason why we
need to lean into
this is for these down bout races
there's races like in Missouri where
Josh Holly's up for re-election in Texas
where Ted Cruz is up for election and
those are going to be difficult those
are going to be difficult races folks
difficult races and the more people we
turn out the better chance that we have
to win some of those seats in the Senate
back we're going to win the house don't
worry about that either Jesus that's
[__] easy these people can't do [__]
they're the they're I mean all they can
do is think about Hunter Biden's [__]
and when are they going to shut down the
government it's not a [__] selling
platform a winning message with the
American people
okay I mean Jesus Christ the Republicans
had had to OU a speaker they want to ask
this La this this speaker now because he
won't shut down the government and they
had to ask the best Republican that they
had the model Republican that they had
George Santos for crying out loud they
took him out of Congress what' they do
that for he's the best Republican there
is I mean he loves all the Republican
lies he loves to live the Republican
lies
but this is so important that the media
get this right and it doesn't matter if
it's cable news if it's Joe in the
morning or ma or Willie gist or if it's
Lawrence in the evening or Rachel mattow
or joeanne Reed or Ari
melbour are in the afternoon if it's uh
what's the the day day the Nicole
Wallace I I don't know I I don't watch
any of this [__] the only thing I really
listen to is Joe scarber in the morning
and most of the time I make it through
15 minutes of that [__] and I get so
pissed off I turn that [__] off I can't
stand
it and I don't want to poison my
commentary you know what I mean there is
that thing that happens that's and
that's the whole point poisoning
commentary because people like Tony you
Tony you shouldn't speak out against
people on the
left why why should why shouldn't I why
shouldn't I point out that they're doing
it wrong don't we want to do it right
shouldn't we want to do it right
shouldn't we want our commentary to
drive a message that can win
everywhere what the [__] are you talking
about what the hell are you talking
about you don't you don't want me to
point out when they're doing it really
shitty like a lot of people get offended
when I talk about David Pacman which
haven't done in a while so maybe I
should add him to the list the necessary
list David Pacman is boring as [__] he's
[__] boring the reason why he's
boring is because he's syndicated on
radio and you can't curse on radio you
can't get too excited on leftwing talk
radio because they're [__] fro Loops
I don't you shut your mouth when you're
talking to
me no
idea and a lot of people like Pac-Man
I'm gonna get a [__] in the thing I like
Pac-Man I like Pac-Man I like Pacman I
like and Patricia says leave minus touch
out of it I like them I didn't say you
shouldn't like them that's not what I'm
saying it's not what I'm saying you guys
are missing what I'm
saying that there is more important
things than
ads there's more important things than
selling [__] gummies lawn juice 1,000
that's why I make fun of it there's more
important things than talking about
every single [__] stupid thing
because because somehow you believe it
to be relevant or just so you can sell
another YouTube
ad there's something more at stake here
it's called a democracy it's called our
country it's called the Constitution
there's something really at
stake I truly believe that deep down
inside my
bones and I believe that we can we can
we can shape the narrative we can get it
going so having said that let's shape
some narrative because I believe there's
someone else listening possibly um
someone pointed this out on Facebook
James Carville we played a few clips of
James Carville now James Carville did a
video and I watched most of this video
but I'm going to show you from it it's
[__] hilarious and James Carbell is
like hey we need to mock these
[__] we need to mock these
[__] the media is doing a
horrible job he says it he says it in
this video not me not me not me James
carille says we're doing a he even says
he's done a shitty job that he hasn't
done it correctly um so he goes through
a proper mocking here and here's one of
the ways that he mocks Trump it's great
listen we have to communicate moly so
let me give you an example you're
looking at the background all right I
have three years here one 1996 One
1999 one 2000 one 2003 it's a multiple
choice what is now Trump is fat okay
he's really fat they put on his physical
he weighs 230 pounds I tell I'll make
anybody this bet Trump you get on the
schu scale and every pound under 230
I'll pay you a th if every pound over
230 you pay me
$10 and I'm going to the bank so the
question
is what is the last year you think that
Trump actually saw his dick I think it's
2000 I don't think he's seen it in this
Century remember the century really
doesn't start till January 1st 2001 it's
kind of weird thing but I I give him the
benefit of that that's what that's how
fat what a fat piece of [__] I think he
is now there's some there's another part
about oh my God that's what of fat piece
of [__] I know what what year do you
think was the last year that Trump has
seen his
dick ah James Carville really leaning
into really leaning into mocking Trump
and getting and getting it all up in
in and you know you know Trump listens
to James garville right like Trump sees
garville and if if he he knew that James
Carville was talking about how he had
and see his dick Trump would pay
attention I bet he would write a true
social about it almost immediately but
there someone else who mocks who mocks
president Trump greatly and it is is the
guy with the last name sanchz watch this
clip I hope everybody is listening
because we have some very important
information for you to make sure we win
this primary and we win it big it all
starts right here in Iowa with the first
and the nation caucuses that I was able
to give to Iowa I controlled it and I
gave it just as I said I would wait hold
on Iowa hosted the Democratic party's
opening presidential contest for the
first time in January 1972 and
Republicans followed 4 years later sorry
but something just doesn't add up here
bear with me for a sec as I put on my
handy dandy magga thinking cap to do
some quick math Democrats started the
caucus in 1972 and Republicans joined
four years later 1976 Donald Trump was
born in 1946 making him 30 years old
which is about the same age that Jesus
was when he first started his ministry
Ministry is eight letters 7 plus 5 plus
8al 20 and 7 plus 6 plus 2al 15 which
makes 2015 the year that Trump announced
that he was running for president Trump
used time travel to invent the Iowa
caucus I hope everybody is listening
because we have some
very oh everyone's saying they miss Gabe
Sanchez they miss Gabe Sanchez in the
chat he's here on Fridays he's here on
Fridays for bonehead of the week and he
puts out his what was that with Gabe
Sanchez on his YouTube channel so go to
the Tony michaels.com let me show you
how to find everything Gabe Sanchez you
just go to the Tony michaels.com let me
flip over here you pan all the way down
to everything Gabe Sanchez there's his
links there there's his YouTube channel
there's his twitch Channel make sure to
go follow Gabe Sanchez in all those
areas if you miss Gabe Sanchez so you
can see all the videos he posts on his
YouTube channel and on his social
media don't forget to go follow the guy
with the last name Sanchez if you're
missing if you're missing him uh so um
but I I I he sent me that clip last
night and I was like oh this is genius
so then he he proceeded to post it on
social media so I'm glad he did I'm glad
Gabe is posting more Clips on social
media all right um here's
a you want to talk about some mockery
you want to get some good mockery and
get a good laugh what is the last year
you think that Trump actually saw his
dick here is I think I think I forget
that this lady she's a tick tocker and
I've seen this this video years ago this
video is not new but I come across it
again on on Twitter and I had to repost
it um here it is listen to the mockery
in this one this one's great well hell
y'all the Cheeto humping [__] nuggets
are out in force this morning geez so
Pete I
mean this woman just sent me a message
saying that she's going to quit
following me because I'm a Biden she
and she didn't realize
it [__] where have you
been Jesus Christ you people are nuttier
and [__] squirrel
turds get it together you have three
granddaughters vote for their rights
pull your head out of your
ass well hell y'all the Cheeto humping
[__] nuggets again are out in force this
morning oh the Cheeto humping [__]
nuggets I don't that's pretty good I
mean it's long but so is Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan right It just
fits it fits perfectly even though it's
even though it's long the Cheeto humping
[__] nuggets the Cheeto humping [__]
nuggets I don't know um Tracy has a
question here and Tracy I wanna I want
to share with you what my thoughts on
this is um because Tracy says how is fat
shaming
okay how is fat shaming okay uh fat
shaming isn't okay it isn't okay and our
country is not okay our democracy is not
okay there's people in our country that
are not
okay we're it's not and mocking mocking
is going to put us in a position where
we're going to have to do things that
aren't generally accepted as okay and
that's okay it's okay and sometimes it
takes people like me saying things that
like I say to offend certain people to
shake things
loose that's what everyone needs to
understand is some of these things need
to be said to shake things
loose you can't run around dancing
around on Ang shells when you got Nazis
trying to take power in your government
to overturn the
Constitution we can't afford to stand
around and decide well are we goingon to
not use mockery are we going to not mock
these people because mockery is very
important and it's very important how to
understand how to use
mockery it's very important how to use
it punching up is almost crucial with
mockery so when you fat shame you
definitely do not punch down it is
something that you do not
do that's offensive in my view punching
up using any kind of mockery that we can
to make sure that our democracy lives
another day well
I'm willing to get in the mud I'm
willing to get in the monk I'm willing
to survive the dumpster
fire to do that
yes there's almost nothing I may not say
to save our country to save our
constitution to protect to protect this
great nation and the idea the American
experiment for future Generations
there's almost nothing I may not say to
do that no matter who it offends no
matter who it upsets no matter who
leaves the audience because they don't
like what I say when I say it how I say
it it's just the way it is and we've got
to get used to this idea on the
left that we are we are going to be
offended and people are going to get
offended by the [__] we are going to say
they're going to and some of the [__]
we're gonna say may not be socially
acceptable in most
cases may not be
and that's why I don't have any big
corporate sponsors that's why it's why
certain people don't want to be on my
show because they can't be associated
with that well if you can't be
associated with the with the fist that
is going to beat Nazis back to save our
democracy I don't know what you're going
to be associated
with because there is just nothing that
I might not say I I can't tell you what
the limit would
be to me saving my
democracy it just is and if you use
mockery in the proper
way with comedy humor and you punch up
you punch up that's the most important
part of it all now when you gain a
platform right when you gain a platform
and you come bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger punching up
gets harder and harder and harder
because there's no one above you anymore
right there's no one to punch up too you
are the power you are the
influence so it has to come from certain
directions certain
people the best part is is I can teach
you how to punch up how to mock how to
dog them in the comments how to drive
away the trolls it's what I do when I
pull Shaz
in Shaz is my equal I mean Jesus Christ
he types in more Facebook messages than
I do that's why I call it Shaz in the
shark Army it's very important that you
distinguish a single person with a group
of people when you have a group of
people who go to Iowa to vote 51% in a
way of a traitor you can mock them you
can mock them you can mock them in
Mass it's very important to keep that in
mind mockery is the key here it is what
will drive our
messaging it is what will
continue after our
democracy and that's where the media
fails the media fails because they don't
they don't mock properly um you want
another good mockery I showed this the
other day it was Jeremy London come up
with it and he typed out Trump is going
to build a Iron Dome over the country
and make martians pay for proper mockery
from Jeremy London the other day Trump
said that he was going to have an Iron
Dome remember remember he said I'm going
to build an iron Dome over the country
now I think he meant like Iron Dome like
Israel has an iron dome which is a
missile defense system it's just a name
for a missile defense system but when he
said it I'm sure a lot of his [__]
followers like oh that' be really cool
so we won't see the sky anymore unless
Trump opens the
dome right I'm sure a lot of the sheep
bought it that way I decided to mock
Trump I decided to mock him by making
him say it Trump is going to build an
iron Dome over the country and make the
Martians pay for it Trump
is proper mockery proper mockery not
only not only is um it mockery towards
Donald Trump but we use Donald Trump in
his own words and his own voice to mock
him properly yeah you want to see
another if you want to see another uh
proper mockery here's joyan Reed here's
MSNBC here's me praising them on
MSNBC uh for absolutely destroying Ronda
Sanz watch this I think we must remark
upon the absolute tragedy of Ronda
santis as a human being and as a
politician and I say this as somebody
who spent 14 years in the great state of
Florida this man torched the state of
Florida's education system by turning it
into a a grand apologist for slavery he
passed a six week abortion ban that he
signed at midnight so that no one could
see him do it to match Kim Reynolds the
governor of Iowa in essentially
condemning uh rape victims and incest
victims to give birth at 10 years old if
that's what it takes in order to get
evangelicals to like him all the things
he did he completely um took the the the
the Republican Tallahassee entire Senate
and House delegations put them in his
service they had to essentially work for
him and they passed everything he asked
them for for one reason only because he
was going to win Iowa yeah he put it all
on Iowa his whole ground game is Iowa
his whole strategy is Iowa and he
destroyed his political career in his
home state neglected his home state
during two hurricanes wore weird high
boots and humiliated himself when he
finally ran home to pretend that he was
going to help his State and neglected it
the highest insurance rates it's
impossible to get insurance in the State
uh workers are leaving his Latino
workers Hispanic workers are leaving
because of draconian immigration law
that his uh Republicans passed for him
it's hurting the agriculture industry
the construction industry he's ruined
the state made it an anathema for
business he sued Disney put himself at
war with Mickey Mouse and lost and got
humiliated by them what has he not done
that was stupid politically all for one
purpose he did the ad where he said God
created a fighter to get Evangelical to
love him and he's going to finish maybe
in the 15s maybe in the 20s in Iowa and
he's finished as a politician in Florida
as a result also when Rachel said boom
proper mockery talking about the m boots
talking about the Mickey Mouse there you
go and she didn't have to Fat shame in
it I guess Tracy points out fat shaming
hurts
everyone look I've been fat before in my
life I've been a big dude before and um
you know it's not it's not fun to do
these things but you know we've gotta
win we have to win and I know you're
like Tony you can win without listen if
it takes a little bit of mockery of
trump and his weight wait to get him all
upset and to get him all in a tizzy to
point out how ridiculous he is and to
show the world how ridiculous he is and
it pulls people to say you know what
maybe maybe I should consider the other
old guy maybe that's what I should do
maybe I should maybe I should maybe I
shouldn't drink the Kool-Aid maybe I
shouldn't drink the
Kool-Aid so here's the game plan we're
going to add more Kool-Aid to the mix
and I'm not just talking a sprinkle here
and a Dash there no no no we're going
Full Throttle people I want this punch
to be so vibrant so bursting with flavor
that it's practically doing a dance in
the picture
oh it's doing a dance in the picture I
don't know you decide is that real or is
it AI I don't know I I couldn't tell is
he is he Jones or is he not is he not um
but again these are the things that we
have to do I showed you a video
yesterday of God made made Trump
smells proper mockery more mockery
that's going to get them I mocked
yesterday Charlie Kirk and all the simps
the incel simps out there for hating on
Taylor Swift Mo them as well proper
mockery these are the things that we
must and have to do and James gville is
on to something like he's completely
onto something it works out just
marvelously um maybe I should uh maybe I
should try to get Carville on the show
and we can talk about mockery and why it
would work maybe we'll do that maybe
I'll call him maybe I'll call him let's
take a break I'll see if I can get James
carille on the line see if he wants to
come on the show and I don't know maybe
eat some pizza with
me we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you ready for best Pizza of
Life bring friends down to pepperoni hug
spot our chefs make pizza with heart and
Special Touch cheese pepperoni vegetable
and more secret things need delivery
pizzas come fast knock knock who's there
pizza magic eat pepperoni hugs spot
Pizza your tummy say thank you your
mouth say mm pepperoni hug spot it's
like family but with more
cheese catch Tony's twitch stream the
[__] list Roundup at
twitch.tv/ thony Michaels we're back to
the king of Brilliance this is the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast welcome back to the
show speaking of mockery you want to
mock some white Christian nationalist do
you do you I want to I want to knock
some white chisan ashas uh Mike Mike
Flynn is um really pissed off apparently
I've got a GL here of of Mike Flynn
maybe he'll sue me I don't know he likes
to sue people uh that call him a white
Christian nationalist he is one so what
do you want me to do H but Mike Flynn is
very upset that mikro Johnson the wiener
of the house is
using his faith his fake faith I don't
know let's listen let's see what Mike
Mike Flynn is mad at Mike Johnson for
not shutting down the government listen
we all had Great Hopes from speaker Mike
Johnson speaker Mike Johnson is turning
out to be this this this sort of he's
actually he uses his I call it his phony
Faith now as a screen for wh what app
appears to be great great weakness I
mean they they're doing nothing they are
absolutely doing nothing and they could
they could shut this government
down so so Mike Flynn is really upset
that Mike Johnson is using his fake
Faith
okay oh my God you can't make this [__]
up when I said earlier that the that MAA
is in a civil war within the Republican
party I'm dead
serious these people these people cannot
stop [__] trying to get them these
people out of the party that won't do
their bidding so Mike Johnson has a job
he ran for the job he got the speaker of
the house I actually didn't think Mike
Johnson would get the votes on the first
ballot I was really surprised by that I
was completely caught off guard I I have
to admit I did not think Mike Johnson
would win that vote on the first ballot
but he did I was
wrong but Mike Johnson has a job now and
his number one job is to I don't know
like do the business of the house and
one of the only ways to do the business
of the house is to keep the government
open like that's one of the things that
he has to do like it's his job to make
sure those Appropriations happen it's
how it works that's how it's all set up
the House of Representatives
appropriates funds that are the taxpayer
dollars and the executive branch writes
the check okay it's how it works the
Congress appropriates funds they set the
budget they say what the executive
branch is going to spend money on and
how they're going to spend it but these
shitty want the government shut down and
the reason why they went the government
shut down is because they really think
that it'll show how derel and the and
his duty that Biden is that somehow this
is gonna hurt Joe Biden right that's the
reason why they keep yapping about the
border border this border that Jesus
this God that you know what I mean these
white Christian
nationalists Mike Flynn wants the
government shut down these [__] eaters
these traitors by the
way I took a huge [__] this morning and
it smelled so much like a traiter that I
named it Mike Flynn that's when I named
it I it was it was disgusting it smelted
horrible it smelt like a [__] traitor
so I I named it Mike Flynn but let's
finish uh to see what this pile of [__]
has to say they could bring more people
in for uh they could subpoena more
people to come in to actually hold
people accountable and yet they don't
what so he wants to shut down the
government and then he does then he
wants to do government things which is
it Mike which is it you pile treason of
[__] which is it you want to do
government or do you not want to do
government it's very [__] confusing
and it's not supposed to make sense
honestly it's not supposed to make sense
sense a lot of this is sheep food if you
want to know the honest truth and
there's no better sheep feeder than than
General Lieutenant General former
Lieutenant General Mike Flynn um here is
another clip of Mike Flynn from that
same one and it's really weird um
because he brings up Adolf Hitler here
we go Eric Holder was out speaking on
behalf of Obama yesterday talking about
how how dangerous it will be if Donald
Trump comes back into office and and the
reason why they're saying that is
because they are trying to put any
propaganda out there to to tell to get
people especially young people like JT
the 40 and unders the 30 and unders to
make them believe that Donald Trump is
the second coming of Adolf
Hitler now um
Mike uh add off add off really listen to
how he says it again listen listen
listen especially young people like JT
the 40 and unders the 30 and unders to
make them believe that Donald Trump is
the second coming of Adolf
Hitler listen he said it rat did you
hear that rat did you hear that did you
hear it he said Donald Trump is the
second coming of Adolf Hitler I don't
know maybe we should pull that sound and
play it more often I don't know here
let's listen again let's listen again
see if you can hear it see young people
like JT the 40 and unders the 30 and
unders to make them believe that Donald
Trump is the second coming of Adolf
Hitler Mike Flynn said it Mike Flynn
said it what listen folks it's working
this is how narrative works okay so what
we do is we create a narrative and when
we create a narrative on offense they
have to be on
defense so Mike Flynn has to go on these
shows and defend defend Donald Trump
that he's not at whatever you're hearing
stop don't hear it don't listen to it he
really isn't the second coming of Adolf
Hitler Adolf Hitler he really says it he
pronounces it in a certain way that
really makes him smell like a treasonous
Nazi doesn't it listen to how he says it
again listen unders the 30 and unders to
make them believe that Donald Trump is
the second coming of Adolf Hitler Adolf
hit Adolf Hitler how Adolf Hitler that
doesn't it really sound like he's saying
it like that do it really sound like
that I don't know maybe I'm wrong let's
keep listening though when the second
coming of Adolf Hitler Joseph Stalin and
mounty Tong combined is Barack Obama
you're not going to hear anybody talking
like that because people are too afraid
of that
man Barack Obama the guy who was
president for eight years and didn't
send people to concentration camps
didn't take your [__] guns what what
the [__] are you talking about man by by
their account Joe Biden is Barack Obama
2.0 and they still haven't come taking
your [__] guns what a bunch of
[__] Bon heads you think you would
think that Barack Obama would be such a
good [__] Mau and Adolf Hitler that
for eight years under his presidency and
now three years under Biden he would
have got little further with the
concentration camps of putting
conservatives in the concentration camps
and taking all their guns get the [__]
out of here with this [__] the [__]
out of here with this
nonsense Barack Obama somehow in power
and he's the a get the [__] if that's
the truth then Barack Obama is the worst
[__] Hitler in the history of Hitlers
okay he's the world's worst dictator
because of what he represents oh oh what
he represents oh that's what he
represents he means black he means black
and he means Muslim this that's what he
means I don't know because Hitler wasn't
black and Hitler wasn't a Muslim so I
don't know what the [__] that has to do
with
it Hitler was a Christian nationalist
though I don't know if you know that
that's how it all started that's how it
all started in Germany I don't know if
you know that
maybe you should it started with
Christian nationalism and then it became
White Christian nationalism white
Christian nationalism all right let's go
to another clip here that right-wing
watch has uh speaking of white Christian
Nationalist and here is uh it's funny
it's funny because um I've been saying
white Christian Nationalist and I've
been showing a lot of right-wing uh
watches um um tweets and videos on this
show no one else really shows them the
mainstream media doesn't show them uh
big huge channels out there don't show
them I don't know why it's the [__]
disease that is rotting our country why
they're aren't going to the source of
what is rotting our country to point out
to people why it's rotting our country
so they can go tell other people why
it's rotting our country so people know
what the [__] is rotting our country so
we can get on with this [__] get on with
this [__] get these [__] Nazis out of
our goddamn governments and get on with
democracy get on with it for crying out
loud Trump is not the [__] problem
white Christian nationalist is the
disease Trump is the symptom of the
disease let me show you here but I'm
finally I'm glad that right-wing watch
is finally starting to catch on to the
narrative because they're describing
Nick Fuentes here which you guys know
Nick Fuentes uh shown here in this video
and I'm going to show you the video here
he's the one he's the Nazi because he is
a Nazi he's the one that went down to
Mar Lago and met with Donald Trump he
met with Donald Trump with Kanye West
Kanye West the one who also loves Adolf
Hitler apparently almost as much as Mike
Flynn that [__] traitor can believe
that Donald Trump is the second coming
of Adolf Hitler he is he's the Donald
Trump is the second coming of Adolf
Hitler apparently according to Mike
Flynn um here is here is Nick ventes but
right-wing watch look at this look at
this they're starting white National
Christian fascist anti-semitic white
nationalist Christian oh man they're
getting so close white Christian
nationalist they're getting so close to
picking up the Tony M what Tony Michaels
is is dropping down Yep they're almost
picking up they're smelling what I'm
stepping in folks they're smelling what
I'm stepping in and that's the key
that's what I keep telling you about
narrative and cascading the message
so I keep telling you that's why we work
every day every day for two hours and we
go on and on and on and I repeat myself
because I know a lot of people like
Jesus Christ only repeats himself every
[__] day yes that's what it takes
that's what it takes that's what it will
take and the thing is is if you don't
share this stuff if you don't go tell
people man you gotta listen to this guy
this [__] guy's crazy he says some
crazy [__] it's two hours you get him
here they'll watch and then they'll come
back and they'll come back and they'll
come back and they'll come back and
it'll finally start to sink in like it's
sunk in with right-wing watch where
they're calling Nick Fuentes the
anti-semitic white nationalist Christian
fascist now he declares that Donald
Trump is his cult he's a cultist well we
knew that but let's listen to Nick in
his own words I am a trump cultist and I
want everyone to know that I am not a
republican do not lump me in with them I
am not a republican I do not support
McCarthy I do not support McConnell I do
not support Haley or santis I do not
watch Fox News I don't support any of
that I am a Donald Trump cultist I am a
soldier for Donald Trump I am part of I
serve at the personal pleasure of Donald
Trump my supreme leader I am part of the
paramilitary wing of the Trump movement
I am part of the Revolutionary guard I
do not answer to the Pentagon I do not
answer to the civilian government I
answer I am the petorian guard of Donald
Trump if Donald Trump ordered me to do
an extra judicial killing I would
perform
it he's a Donald Trump cultist yeah we
all knew
that we knew that we knew that he's a
Donald Trump
cultist
obviously but again do you think do you
think the mainstream media is gonna pick
up that clip what about the clip about
the I don't know a Theocratic monarchy
you think they'll pi that one up huh I
don't know maybe they will maybe they
won't let's see what some pastors have
to say though let's listen uh the Bible
tells us that whenever the wicked are in
power the people Gran and uh you know
it's quite obvious right now Americans
across the board Republican Democrats
conservative liberals black white rich
poor Americans are groaning uh nothing
seems to be going right in our nation
everything seems to be going wrong and
the Bible says that that whenever the
Wicked rule the people will groan and uh
you know this and your audience knows
this we have a very very Wicked
individual uh that I don't think he
knows what he's actually doing but he is
carrying out the purposes uh of those
who are pulling the strings and the
Bible then says though that whenever the
righteous rule the people rejoice and I
I remember uh during President Trump's
term Americans were rejoicing everybody
was everyone you know that's the what's
the old add whatever Rising tide list
all in the harbor and so that was what
was happening in America because
president Trump he is a righteous man
now the liberal media they're gonna go
off on something like that how can a a
New York Playboy be a righteous man he
is a righteous man because he does what
is right and he has done what is right
for this country and so we need Donald
Trump back
in office for this nation and so one of
the most effective things that we can do
yes we can all vote uh we can all
volunteer on the campaign but something
even more powerful is we can all
pray I hope I hope they continue to pray
I hope they sit there and continue to
pray um as Yi says blah blah blah yakety
schacky it's all the same old white
Christian nationalist [__] but listen
folks this is the threat this is the
thing that is going to take away our
democracy if we do not pay attention
and we don't get the rest of the nation
to pay the [__]
attention you want another one that you
can send here here's another one God
frequently gives
America better leadership than we
deserve his Mercy is on
us in other words I'm fed up with the
pontificating sanc monious Evangelical
Christian leaders who are constantly
harping a trump and upset and obsessed
about the idolatry of people that love
Trump like what like they're jealous
that he's liked more than they are I
think that's what's bothering them and
the reality is God is giving us
leadership better than we deserve so if
you think Trump is oh he doesn't have
our values doesn't represent what I can
vote for listen up butter cup God's
giving you someone better than you
deserve the country doesn't deserve
Trump the country and God's giving him
us I'm telling you this is dangerous
[__] people and and if you're not paying
attention to [__] like that then you're
not paying attention to what is real and
what is happening and why it's happening
because everyone stands around going why
in the how in the [__] how in the actual
ual [__] can these people believe this
[__] how do people believe this nonsense
how do they stand in a line saying I
want Trump to be a dictator yeah I would
rather have Trump be a dictator and tell
us what the [__] to do and when to do it
and how to do it then have Joe Biden as
the president for four years and then
we'll go on with another president after
that another president after that
another president after that I would
much rather make this a Theocratic
monarchy
a Theocratic
monarchy Edward Sals is the guy who said
that in a video with Laura wisk I showed
it to you I don't know and I'm going to
show it to you again but here he is
about a week
ago here he is standing with the Trump
cap caucus Captain Trump himself now
it's really [__] weird because he's
got a suit on with army boots and I'm
guessing this is because he's in IA
right remember the white Christian
nationalist guy remember the guy I told
you I showed you a video where they're
talking about a Theocratic
monarchy that's just not some [__]
guy okay it's not just some [__] guy
media it's not just some [__] guy
people out there not [__] paying
attention this [__] is in Iowa
with Trump's ear giving the old stupid
ass thumbs up [__] picture
it's not just some guy on some [__]
show
somewhere pay the [__]
attention it's super
important oh you wna you want to see you
want to
see you want to see the video I can show
you the video but let me show you let me
show you another video um of him and him
and L
Lauren went talking about talking about
how they used to treat gay people and
that we should go back to that listen
they used to be a day and age I mean
look one of the primary reasons other
than of course our faith it was just bad
for the kid you think about the kid in
the situation we beat up the kid at
school who had two dads I mean that's
yeah and we weren't jerks for that there
was just I never knew any kid who had
two dads we beat up the kids at school
who had two
dads
okay that guy right there right there
let me let me show you let me show you
let me let me go let me go back and let
me show
you who that guy Pals around
with in
Iowa are you paying attention yet are
you believing me yet you know you can
[__] go listen to commentary about
Gaza you can go listen to commentary
about BB Netanyahu and all the [__]
[__] overseas and all the wars that we
aren't fighting we don't have soldiers
on the ground we don't have authority to
fight same in
Ukraine you can sit and you can ponder
each little motion that happens to this
guy in a court or you can [__] pay
attention to who this guy is courting
out there in the
country and why the problem is the way
it is
okay you can do that you have the right
to do that and you can do both you can
do both you can go listen to commentary
on motions and stuff and you can go
listen to commentary endless commentary
on Israel and Gaza and Palestine and
Ukraine and Russia you can go do all
that this year you can do both you can
do both or what you can do or what the
media can do is do their [__] duty do
their [__] responsibility and report
on [__] like this
report on [__] like this this is the guy
with Laura who's saying we used to beat
up kids who had two dads he's the one
who was advocating for a king Trump King
Trump with a Santa Claus hat
on and he's ping around with him in Iowa
and the reason why Trump's pounding
around with this guy is because this guy
is convincing a thousand thousands and
thousands of this guy's
that that that Trump should be a
Theocratic
Monarch all I'm
asking is that when you listen to media
and you're listening to them and they're
not telling you the whole [__] game
they're not telling you why we got to do
what we got to do in 2024 and the next
election and the next election and why
the narrative is so [__] important
he's so it's so [__]
important and I'm not talking about the
the the foreign policy narrative I'm
talking about right here in this country
the simple Narrative of why Americans
should vote for their leaders not not
try to [__] overthrow or try to get
some other leader to do what they want
in a Sovereign Nation somewhere
else
they want a Theocratic monarchy they
want a dict taster I'll be a dict taster
for a day look I only taste dick I only
taste dick for just one day it'll be
good dick though it tastes so good I
love the taste of dick I want to be your
dick taster I want to be your dick
taster what do you think these two
talked about before and after this
picture huh
Jesus this Jesus that what do you think
what do you think Edward here talk to
with
Trump you think it was how he likes to
call black people jungle bunnies I don't
know listen well I gotta tell you
something about the first date I have my
wife and it's not cringe okay okay find
hilarious I went on a date with her in
Chicago okay we uh went by the pier and
uh you know after dinner after dinner we
witnessed the robbery that's how I knew
she was the one for me we looked at the
this group of black kids about there's
like 40 black kids robbing a Sears the
alarms are going up we're like man this
place is a hell ho I sit there watching
this robbery to this robbery and I'm
like okay she's not leftwing she's not
leftwing she definitely sees that these
uh jungle bunnies are robbing our
country dry okay I can marry this one
jungle bunnies
not my words that's his
words I I
listen I come from White
America and there's a hell lot more
offensive things that you could call
black people than this right here but
this right here is a very [__]
offensive term and the reason why is
because white people love to call them
that
okay this guy right here who calls black
kids in Chicago on a that he saw rob a
store that didn't happen a thing that
didn't happen
okay he's in Iowa giving thumbs up with
this
guy
okay you got
it I know I know it seems weird that no
one else is paying attention to this
type of
stuff but we're right here
here and I'm going to make sure that you
see every single one of these that you
possibly can
see you possibly can
see here here here he is again here's
the one we watched the other day I'm not
going to stop showing this stuff here he
is there are people paying attention to
uh some of the things that are being
threatened threatened as in like we're
aware of crimes a lot of our Compadres
are are aware of crimes so people on the
other side are really starting wonder
what happens if they do indeed Take Back
Control of the country well Rachel mad
believes that not only are we going to
prosecute everybody on that side of the
aisle but there are going to be
executions she said this let's
go I mean I mean after they stand before
a fair
trial then you know the judgment will be
Swift and it will be
just woo so just get rid of them right
just get rid of all the people coko here
is got concerns says Tony I'm going to
leave you if you show one more of these
[__] my blood pressure can't take
this racist [__] I completely understand
I completely understand that but we
can't look
away you can't look away from this stuff
listen this is why we've got ourselves
into such trouble in the first place
it's because the media stopped looking
at this stuff other media Outlets have
stopped looking at this stuff have sto
paying attention to this
stuff they think that the winning
message is to point out all the great
things that Joe Biden has done and I'm
not saying that's not a good part of the
message that's not a good cherry on top
but that's not how voters react that's
not how voters
engage and coko I I I feel you but
please when you do leave if you do leave
because I'm gonna keep showing this
stuff because we have to be we have to
be focused on what the danger in our
democracy is
the danger in our democracy is not trump
it is white Christian nationalism it is
Maga it is American
fascist the America First Nazi
party it is very important that we know
and see the danger to our democracy is
these right-wing fascists that have
taken over the Republican Party doy
Rule and if we look away if we look away
and we just hold hear no evil see no
evil speak no
evil there could be dangerous
consequences and I don't blame you for
not wanting to watch this stuff trust me
I listen to right-wing radio for years
and years and years and maybe what's
wrong with me like Cliff Sher said the
other day it's possible
that it's possible that's what's wrong
with me it's
possible but maybe it's the thing that
it makes me the perfect person to do
this work I don't
know but any
event we have to make sure that the
country knows who these people are and
what kind of control they
have because if we
don't we could lose our capability of
showing
you we could lose our capability of
mocking them we could lose our cap
capability of voting against
them we could lose our capability of
even speaking out against them like I do
on this show listen because we don't
country anymore it's time for a
Theocratic monarchy King Trump for life
let's go hey I think if we had a
monarchy there'd be a lot less
corruption because you can't be bought
you know you don't have to be bought
because you're always in control you
don't have to be paid for with campaign
cash because you're always going to be
in control and you're going to pass it
on to your children and that kind of
thing especially if they do Bloodlines
but very interesting stuff just just a
suggestion doesn't sound too terrible
it's worked uh throughout the majority
of history and uh King Jesus remember
our Lord believes in uh the Theocratic
uh the monarchal
structure the Lord believes the Lord
Jesus God this God that Jesus this Jesus
that who is this guy I don't know but
this other guy seems to know him really
well and really seems to like
him really seems to like
him especially when he comes to support
him in
Iowa to make sure that those
evangelicals show up because they knew
the turnout was going to be in low in
Iowa because the enthusiasm for Trump is
low that's the good news that's the good
news is that there is a Coalition in
this country Loosely put together that
is anti anti-white Christian
Nationalist and that's why they will go
vote against this guy in the white
[__]
hat maybe he should wear white hoods not
white hats you know what I
mean I don't
know it feels like he's getting with the
symbolism
here oh thank you right-wing watch for
all the work they do again you guys
should go follow right-wing watch um and
you can go to actually you can actually
go to rightwing watch.org here's their
Twitter account here here's the website
rightwingwatch dorg you can go to
they've been around since 1980 they're
older than I
am they're older than I am rightwing
watches um it's actually a project of
people for the America Way American way
and they just all they do is modern
expose the activities of radical right
Pol political
organizations that's it and all I do is
I pay attention to their work and I show
you their work and you should show other
people their work and we should continue
to trumpet what the actual problem is
they're trying to tell us what they want
to do to our nation they're trying to
tell you they don't like democracy
they're trying to tell you that they
want you to be them and only them and if
you don't be them then they'll elect a
dictator a Theocratic Monarch who will
make you do that and if they don't do
that hell will put you on
trial we'll put you on trial so go go go
follow rightwing watch um they're again
they're a vital asset in in this huge
battle that we're in for our democracy
and that and the way that they can show
you they can show you video of these
white Christian nationalist saying the
quiet part out loud
saying the quiet part out loud because
they not only do they say the quiet part
out loud but they
continue to get people to pay attention
to lies lies we had Jess Piper on on
Monday I want to show you a video here
that she's making because these these
State sessions are these state
legislators are in full session uh right
now in some of these states and they're
P trying to pass more anti-trans bills
and I want you to pay attention to that
as well same kind of fascism same kind
of white Christian nationalism as we
discussed with Jess Piper on Monday
that's where all this is coming from
rather it's their anti-trans bills it's
it's their anti-woman bills are their
anti School bills it's all white
Christian nationalism is the heart of it
listen I keep seeing comments from folks
about the trans Community saying they
just don't want it shoved down their
throat and here's the thing I have never
had a trans person knock on my door and
try to con convert me I've never had a
piece of literature left on my car from
the trans Community I have never had a
trans person threaten me with Hellfire
if I didn't believe the way they wanted
me to believe I have had a lifestyle
shoved down my throat all my life and
it's never been from a trans
person H I want to kind of wonder what
kind of people is from probably white
Christian
nationalist Tracy saysi love her we all
love Jess Piper Jess Piper Jess Piper is
not only very [__]
intelligent but Jess Piper has a way of
saying it she has a way of putting it
that a lot of Americans can hear that
voice and they can relate to that voice
that's why it's so important to elevate
folks who have that style who have that
voice and who believe what is the truth
which is that white Christian
nationalism is the threat and I
guarantee you if you go over to Jess's
um siof fit says tell it Jess if you go
over to Jess's social accounts you're
very rarely very rarely Gonna Hear Jess
Piper say the words Trump or type in the
word Trump very rarely and I I I I'm
sure it's not exactly intentional that
she's doing that because Jess Piper
really tries to stay at a state level
message because she understands and it's
so important that we have people out
there working hard like she
is at the state level to understand that
hey a lot of [__] that happens is at the
state level she explained on Monday that
Republicans in the state are passing
passing laws so that will get to the
Supreme Court to change federal
law and federal standards of
law so go follow Jess Piper she knows
the threat I know she knows the threat
she was here on Monday talking about it
so Tracy says I follow je all Jess's
socials
great Go Get It Go Get It um so we have
that uh let's see let's see if we got
any news uh from the courtroom I think
we do have some news from the courtroom
here is a a little piece uh of quotes
from the courtroom you're going to love
this cap L CL Kaplan threatened to kick
Trump out of court after Carol's Council
complained again about Trump's
commentary Kaplan says quote Mr Trump
has the right to be present here that
can be forfeited and the judge goes on
to say Mr Trump I hope you don't have to
consider ex I have to consider excluding
you from The
[Laughter]
Trial oh boy after that here is
after after Trump threw his hands up in
the air and said I would love it judge
Kaplan continued I know you would Kaplan
said I know you would you just can't
control yourselves in this circumstance
apparently he has he has the right to
remain silent but he doesn't have the
[__] ability he does not have the
[__] ability to shut the [__] up he
just
doesn't oh that's fantastic I love those
quotes right out of the courtroom H so
that that happened now is about about a
half hour ago 45 minutes ago those
quotes are and I think they're still in
the courtroom now let's see if I can
find let's see if I can find some
footage to see if they took a break or
something uh to see if we can get any
kind of footage out of the courtroom you
know I told you this morning that Alina
habas and that's kind of the the
headline is egene Carroll is testifying
against against Trump she gave an
opening statement Trump wouldn't even
look at her in court wouldn't even
glance an eye at her in court um but
let's see if we can
get it doesn't look like they've taken a
break yet honestly it doesn't it doesn't
appear that they have walked out of the
courtroom so they still must be in uh
the courtroom and they still must be
listening to some of this trial so and I
don't know if the judges actually booted
Trump from the courtroom but has
threatened to and he keeps talking
loudly again I showed you the quote
earlier where uh Trump is turning to his
attorneys and talking to his attorneys
so that people in the courtroom can hear
what he's saying
um but that is what it is here so maybe
we'll get um maybe we'll get something
out of this courtroom of course all the
Trump siop fants are really upset that
this trial is happening and that Trump
is going to be losing more money which I
mean this is no fault of his own but
again like the judge said you can't shut
your [__]
mouth you can't shut your [__] mouth
and he does he he has the right to
remain silent but he does not have the
ability um here's another report from
Victor it says reports saw that during
the 15-minute break Ean Carroll's lawyer
was complaining about the fact that
Trump was speaking
loudly during eeg's testimony saying
it's false and she got her memory back
the break is over the judge immediately
asked him to stop um so this is what led
up to um him telling telling Trump to
shut the [__]
up was Ean Carroll's lawyer saying hey
he's talking loudly and he's saying
stuff like she got her memory back and
he's saying the same [__] that they post
like in your comments right it's the
same [__] it's the same cultist ass [__]
that they posted your comments about
this shut your mouth when you're
talking um and Victor goes on this
report here Trump knows exactly what
he's doing and I'm glad judge Kaplan is
calling him out for this we'll see if
Trump actually listens now no he won't
he won't listen egene is now back
testifying the trial has resumed this is
one hour ago um so apparently we're
we're still in resumption of that
trial let's see if we
can I'm trying to find see if there was
um I want a video I want a video of
Donald Trump outside the courtroom
saying the same [__] he's trying to say
inside the courtroom because you know
when he walks out he's gonna say the
[__] that he's saying in the courtroom
when and he's defaming her in the
courtroom like he's actively defaming
her in the
courtroom the same the same way that
he's
gotten charged money for this defamation
he's doing the same thing in the
courtroom and the judge is trying to
prevent him from it I actually think the
Judge should continue letting him dig
his own grave here just let him keep
spending money maybe that's what the
judge should do say you know what we'll
just open up a line of credit and every
time you say something against e Carol
we'll just we'll just debit that line of
credit you'll have to pay for it with
interest um maybe that'll be good or you
know what would be better I think I
think it would be great if they ordered
him to give egene Carol Mara Lago and
then she just went down there with a
dozer and bulldozed that [__] down
surely the money that he'll give her and
the the because we know that Mar Lago
ain't worth but you know a couple bucks
he claims it's worth a billion and a
half dollars but you know that [__]
ain't true I mean I don't know that's a
pretty good idea maybe we should see if
we could get judge judge Kaplan just to
award egene Carroll Mara Lago so she can
bulldoze it
down it's my thought just a thought all
right let's go let's go back to uh um
see if there's anything else trending in
the news oh oh by the way that this it
seems like speaking of the speaker of
the house earlier it seems like that
they're actually going to uh keep the
government open because the speaker of
the house has learned that he that he
needs to keep the government open I'm
not sure if that'll happen or not um I I
have my doubts I really do that the
government will stay
open again they're going to do a a CR A
continuing resolution for just a couple
months to try to try to continue to go
uh on about it
but it doesn't appear that there is
any any footage outside the courtroom of
Donald Trump defaming
eing Carol yet and I stress yet as a big
one there is some news about Shan
Hannity Shan Hannity apparently is
trending and he's really upset um and
he's really jealous of Rachel matal so I
guess we'll take a look at that ifying
tone uh but apparently according to
part-time make-believe journalists and
full-time left-wing hate Trump
conspiracy theorists like radical Rachel
mattow while Trump speech was too
dangerous for the fragile ears of NBC's
loyal viewers they didn't take any of
the speech live instead no Miss mattow
was lecturing Americans about truth and
integrity uh this is a joke right
serious question does mattow not have
any self-awareness at all oh my God so
he's calling Rachel Mato Teno hat
TV Fox News that's rich that's
rich oh boy I have I have a vinmo chat
here a vinmo Super Chat that I want to
put up on the screen it is from Nicole
Nicole says hey Tony just a heads up try
not to drink alcohol before the night of
getting your tattoo because it'll make
you bleed more and that may make some of
the color bleed out Nicole e thank you
Nicole for the venmo Super Chat and
thanks for the advice a lot of people
were asking this the other day you know
that I'm going to be getting a tattoo on
January 26 if you want uh to help with
that tattoo if you want to see the
tattoo live stream just go to the Tony
michaels.com go under C tattoo Liv
stream contribute to the team tattoo
fund any amount dollar $2 whatever you
want and I will get you an email to give
you all those links to the live streams
when I'm getting my tattoo but this is a
great Point Nicole because people were
saying the other day when I was talking
about this on the Sunday rant um they
were talking about how I should probably
get wasted before I get my tattoo but
Nicole brings up a good point here so I
actually I I don't think I'm going to I
don't think I'm actually going to get
wasted number one I want you guys who
are going to see the live stream if you
if you participate in the live stream I
want you guys to see real in in
live real time me being in pain uh if
it's painful for me I'm getting it right
here on my arm this is the first part of
the sleeve is my that the microphone
will go right here and it'll say this
machine kills fascist um and that's
where to go on my arm and then the
second part is going to be the Statue of
Liberty right here on my inner forarm
now that'll be the second round that'll
be in February but this first first
session is next week Friday on the 26
and if you want to get the live stream
and access to the live stream uh just go
to neony michaels.com click on the team
tattoo fun any amount that you want
you'll get in on that and thank you
Nicole thank you so much uh for your
advice there and thank you for the vinmo
chat as well if you guys want to get in
on the vinmo chat you just pan on down
you can hit venmo Super Chat right there
or you can buy me a shot it is Wednesday
I'll be doing karaoke tonight so I'd be
doing plenty of Jagger shots or if you
just swear as much as me you can throw
some money in the swear jar also join
the patreon for
free but if you want to be a paying
member and help keeping this microphone
powered on against fascism you can buy
buy you a yearly membership for 10% off
or you can pay by the month that way you
can cancel any time if I say [__] that
hurts your feelings or anything you know
what I
mean oh the Tony Michaels podcast go
check out the tattoo live stream for me
be a part of Team tattoo everyone keeps
saying team tattoo in the in the
chat so make sure to get in on the
tattoo live stream January 26 is when
I'll beginning it # team tattoo I
appreciate all your support I appreciate
you being here on this Wednesday for two
full hours as you are every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on the
Facebook on the tubes of you the twitch
machine and the
Instagrams folks same time same place
tomorrow surf up [__] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast podcast in your face commentary
of current events in political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
thee Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them
Murphy's muor head ass
speaking
well hell y'all the Cheeto humping [__]
nuggets are out in force this morning
geez o Pete I
mean this woman just sent me a message
saying that she's gonna quit following
me because I'm a Biden sheepo and she
didn't realize
it [__] where have you been
Jesus Christ you people are nuttier and
[__] squirrel
turds get it together you have three
granddaughters vote for their rights
pull your head out of your
ass